j'ai retrouvé mon père il joue au brésil
un peu top il faut que tu viennes avec
moi david non mais juste quelques jours
attendre au brésil ah ouais quand même
on est à rio quand même david rio de
janeiro des sources et là il m'a donné
rendez vous ici papa dont 3 jantes et à
paris c'est promis que tu serais rentré
à temps j'ai mon bac de philo tu roules
un spliff théo je sais que tu en as
enfin ça fait des mois que je plains mec
normal que c'est bien tu parle et
comprend rien de rien cette conne
grenade emmerdes
dites moi ce que je fais là on est chez
les dames c'est ça tu es là parce que
nous sommes menacés
mais lassés par qui par quoi bordel
vous m'inspirez l'appelait la nature
ncck vegas tu serais pas que arrive ça
c'est gentil ce truc-là gras viola avant
il était normal ou anormal
michel quoi magra viola peut provoquer
les effets secondaires irréversibles
merde j'ai une patate vous dit avec
gonzo on va peut-être faire un enfant
comme un indice avancé
qu'est-ce qu'il a bien cancer ca ou par
sa tombe et l'escroc michel j'aimais
bien plus points contre il ya un homme
de trop dans cette ville shérif alors on
va tranquillement sortir du saloon
hockey beauce et hop tu vas le blessé sa
mère
in america saison 2 à partir du 1er juin
inédit sur city quoi j'arrive pas à
pisser fort niveau matt a jamais été
souple c'est normal